الاجهاد الرقمي يحدث عندما نتلقى حرب
معلومات اضخم بكثير من قدرتنا على معالجته
ومن اعراضه القلق والارهاق يعرف ايضا باسم
الاغراق المعلوماتي او المشقه الرقميه
دراسه حديثه اشرف عليها المرصد الفرنسي
للاغراق المعلوماتي وجدت ان واحدا من
الموظفين استقبلوا رسائل الكترونيه بعد
الساعه الثامنه مساء في اكثر من 50 ليله
في السنه حاللت الدراسه فترات التركيز
الكامل او ساعه واحده من دون ارسال رسائل
بريد الكتروني وقدرت تلك الفتره بنحو 11%
فقط اسبوعيا ما يعني الكثير جدا من
الضوضاء الرقميه
عالم الاوبئه والمدير العام السابق للصحه
في فرنسا يقول ان هذه الازمه مرتبطه
بزياده مخاطر الاصابه بامراض القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه بالاضافه الى تاثيرات
مناعيه اخرى يقترح ذاب ابقاء الشاشه مغلقه
في اوقات معينه واستغلال هذا الفراغ في
ممارسه الانشطه البدنيه او حتى مجرد
الاسترخاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات